[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' à tallinn à
ternir je reçois aujourd'hui awad
menthéour ancien cycliste professionnel
entrepreneurs activistes lanceur
n'alerte qui publie résistants une
autobiographie pas comme les autres
richard martin le fondateur du théâtre
toursky à marseille qui fête son 50e
anniversaire un théâtre mythique
populaire et internationale qui la faute
défendu toute sa vie bec et ongles
jusqu'à faire la grève de la faim
pendant 12 jours en 2009 et le peintre
louis pierre promeneurs qui c'est qui
expose à la galerie frédéric roulettes
avenue de messine à paris et dont on
commence tout de suite pas l'image que
vous avez choisi juan menthéour pour
illustrer notre époque une bien belle
image mais plutôt dramatique
bas ce qui est en train de se jouer et
dramatique notre maison brûle la planète
brûle la planète est en train de
s'écrouler lacets ou je ne sais pas où
ça j'ai trouvé sur internet en tout cas
elle mais elle m'a un peu bouleversé
quand j'ai vu cette femme je crois que
c'est en grâce me dit on qui s'ouvre
dans mon oreille je me doutais que
c'était quelque chose comme ça ou en
croatie ou aux états unis au casa au
canada comme ça a été le cas ces
derniers temps c'est à dire que les
politiques ne prennent pas du tout là la
pleine mesure de ce qui est en train de
se jouer et malheureusement nous
regardons notre maison brûle et en
imaginant que la science la technique va
pouvait venir au secours de sa alors que
ce sera seulement nouveau d'un
changement fondamental des
infrastructures qui nous permettra d'y
remédier alors je les dis à augmenter au
vous avez été cycliste professionnel
vous avez été le premier à décrire le
dup agents en détail dans un livre
intitulé secret défonce dont on avait
beaucoup parlé à l'époque êtes devenu
entrepreneur vous avez développé la
première application de coaching
alimentaire et sportif vous avez fait un
disque de la télévision des best-sellers
vous avez créé un magazine mentor
vous êtes toujours resté un activiste
aujourd'hui vous raconter dans votre vie
d'un résistant aux éditions solar dans
cette autobiographie je vous cite vous
voulez éclairer ce que vous avez de
meilleures avec ce que vous avez pire
c'est plutôt singulier
oui en fait on est tout le temps en
train de
de se draper on sait tout se passait
pour des parangons de verdure autour de
tous faire croire qu'on est des gens
parfaits irréprochable moi je me suis
dit que en éclairant les parties les
plus sombres mais marécages mes
contradictions ce que j'avais au grenier
ce que j'avais à la cave et dans les
gens avaient peut-être mieux me
comprendre et ça déculpabilise ray
certains de la vie qu'ils mènent parce
que la vie elle est dure pour tout le
monde c'est dur de rebondir mais il faut
je crois y faire face et et vous
raconter aussi les échecs que vous avez
connu il y en a eu un certain nombre et
et j'ai l'impression que voulait bien
qui a une dignité dans l'échec quand
même une fierté
de l'échec oui je pense qu'il ya une
certaine noblesse dans l'échec dans la
mesure où
pour rester digne et rester debout
rester debout après avoir été balayés
après avoir beaucoup souffert il faut
bien sûr beaucoup de dignité et puis on
a on est rentré
un petit peu après la fin des années 70
dans une américanisation de la pensée où
il ya que les winners qui comptait y
avait quelque chose d'héroïque dans le
fait de gagner énormément d'argent on a
décomplexé les gens et en l'occurrence
crois que c'est pas ça qui est qui et
émouvant moi je suis beaucoup plus ému
par les misérables quand vigo
lorsque victor hugo parle d'eux parce
qu'il ya quelque chose d'éminemment
bouleversant et digne dans cette misère
et donc notre misère individuel notre
souffrance individuelle peut recouvrir
énormément dignité voire de poésie et
vous estiment aussi que rien n'est
jamais perdu ça veut dire que même
misérable et vous l'avez était pas
seulement financièrement d'ailleurs
mentalement
rien n'est jamais perdu vous pouvez
rebondir alors moi j'ai vu cette naïveté
je pense que je suis encore un grand
enfant et je pense que je deviendrais
peut-être adule lorsque mon père
disparaîtra mais je crois qu'on est
riche de tous les avenirs possibles
nous a mis dans notre processeur des
plugins qui nous font croire que tout
est difficile et irréalisable on doit
rester dans nos casques on doit rester
là où on nous a placés au départ en
réalité on est capable de survoler plein
de territoire dès lors qu'on a envie de
s'y investir de les embrasser est
évidemment un petit peu trop de travail
est forcément le sport de haut niveau
vous à vous détruit dites vous surtout
le cyclisme et la boxe pourquoi ces deux
sports la détruisent plus facilement
ceux qui les pratiquent c'est très
simple lorsque vous faites du sport une
personne normale quand vous étiez
cycliste voilà en 1996 c'était dans une
équipe de world tour je crois que c'est
à paris nice cette photo
lorsqu'une personne normale fait du
sport au moment elle va commencer à
souffrir
encore lui envoie un message et souffre
hélas elle va ralentir elle va s'arrêter
c'est à coire cycliste ou un boxeur
c'est là que ça commence c'est quand on
commence à souffrir et cette souffrance
il faut l'apprivoiser il faut la désirer
il faut l'aimer il faut se blottir
contre elle parce que c'est elle qui va
garantir notre succès c'est elle qui va
définir le champion qu'on peut être le
mythe qu'on peut devenir le temps d'une
journée le temps d'un grand tour le
temps d'une saison et cette souffrance
elle va mettre un virus dans votre
esprit parce qu'à force d'aimer cette
souffrance vous aller la rechercher
partout dans tous les autres
compartiments l'existence et lorsque
vous quittez cette profession ce qui
explique d'ailleurs que la plupart des
sportifs veulent rester dans leur milieu
d'origine pour regarder dans le
rétroviseur existait encore parce que
nulle part ailleurs il ne retrouve ce
sentiment d' absolue ce sentiment de
plénitude dans la souffrance au
paroxysme de l'effort c'est quelque
chose qui nous déglingue qui nous
tourner vers tout ce qui est les paradis
artificiels tout ce qui est artificiel
et qui nous permet de cultiver cette
peine parce qu'on ne s'en défait jamais
vous dites aussi que le déplacement
physique au fond ça devient une drogue
dure
ça ça a été la science l'a prouvé depuis
longtemps forcément une certaine
sécrétion d'endorphines de
catécholamines kitty beauty bouleverse
l'ensemble de nos neurotransmetteur qui
bouleverse les échanges au niveau du
cerveau une trop grande concentration de
testostérone chez un être humain
forcément on devient fou et en plus
c'est lié dans la plupart des sports
malheureusement encore aujourd'hui mais
pourquoi ça ne serait pas dans le sport
potentialiser par les produits dopants
et on devient un peu fou parce qu'on
n'est pas dans une vie normale on n'est
pas on n'a pas des tropismes normaux
mais on ne vit pas dans le même monde
que les autres c'était le sujet de
secret défonce quel effet ça fait à
l'époque c'est une façon pour vous de
brûler vos vaisseaux c'était de sortir
du cyclisme ou si de publier ce livre
moi j'ai vécu une très grande histoire
d'amour avec le vélo secret défense ça a
été une lettre de rupture je faisais une
peinture d'un milieu à la lumière de mon
itinéraire en me disant naïvement parce
que j'ai une
façon peut percevoir la vie je veux me
prendre pour un héros je suis romanesque
et je me disais ça va changer les choses
bon j'ai bien compris par la suite que
ça n'avait rien changé du tout il paraît
qu'il le court encore plus vite le tour
que de que la vôtre époque alors oui
d'abord est court plus vite et puis
surtout il ya des nouvelles technologies
là on sait que armstrong après avoir
beaucoup reçu parce qu'il s'était dopé
parce qu'ils étaient couverts par la
fédé on sait maintenant qu'il avait un
moteur et qu'il avait un compte il avait
tout il avait signé un contrat
d'exclusivité avec le endroit on le
hongrois qui faisait ce moment c'est
vas-y en course est en cours
d'instruction aux états unis il va y
avoir un deuxième scandale le premier
vélo avec un petit moteur caché et ça
existe encore qu'il aurait eue voilà et
là c'est encore plus horrible c'était
clair on descend encore plus bas donc
parce que les limites le dopage qu'un
seul métier tous à armes égales puisque
vous deviez tout non parce qu'il ya le
problème c'est que je vous donne un
exemple très concret moi quand je
commençais à me doper élevé ni limite à
l'époque arbitraires fixées par l'ue
telus l'uci l'union cycliste
internationale était de 50% moi j'étais
tout le temps entre 49 et 51 avec du
kakadu bang ha ouais donc dès que je
prenais de le paix au jeu passé à 56 on
avait des champs qui à la bhl à la base
était à 39 40 quand il était à la juge
quand ils étaient préparés ils étaient à
54,55 donc lui on n'a jamais pu dire
qu'ils prenaient le bo on l'a toujours
protégé et c'est donc problème pour
deschamps pour moi la baise avait frappé
ouais crise si vous voulez
et il a envie de se faire mal ou si vous
le dites qui vient de là et qui va vous
suivre ensuite parce que pouvez vous
nous voyez entrepreneurs fassiez de la
télé fassiez un disque il ya toujours eu
envie de se faire mal alors il ya une
envie de se faire mal au quotidien parce
qu'on veut maintenir
un certain équilibre au niveau de son
apparence c'est à dire il ya un rapport
méritocratique dans la discipline
sportive à la fois pour l'esthétisme du
corps mais à la fois entre guillemets
pour la santé mais quand tout va bien on
a toujours quelque chose qui nous aspire
la tentation du vide et cette tentation
du vide elle nous appelle avec plein
d'autres artifices qui nous permettent
de cultiver notre peine je parle des
toxicos de la toxicomanie au sens large
de l'alcool de tous les paradis
artificiels
l'argent aussi
l'argent et le sexe sont des formes
d'addiction qui qui sont qui sont
complètement consubstantielle au sport
professionnel parce que c'est souvent
des gens qui viennent de milieux plutôt
défavorisés ou en tout cas il faut avoir
très faim pour rentrer pour faire du de
la boxe pour faire du vélo c'est à dire
faire 35 ou 40 mille kilomètres par an
des sacrifices monstrueux faut vraiment
avoir sacrément fin et du jour on accède
à un certain standing du condensat
gagner beaucoup d'argent eh bien il ya
une certaine frénésie à la fois dans la
dépense de l'argent dans une frénésie
sexuelle pour pour se sentir vivant
parce qu'on a toujours une pulsion de
mort qui compte est de continuellement
là de par ce rapport inextricable à la
souffrance et c'est eros et thanatos le
cul avec la mort et aussi ce truc de
d'améliorer les performances qui
disparaît finalement parce que on aime
ce truc là c'est ça qui est dangereux
avec fitness vous créer une start up
vous lancer dans les levées de fonds
dans tout ce qui est le business
aujourd'hui c'est lady c'était la
première application de coaching
alimentaire et sportif
c'est parce que vous sortiez de l'enfer
d'une forme d'enfer que vous
que vous vous lancer là-dedans stano un
autre erwann menthéour à ce moment là
enfin pas tout à fait un autre
d'ailleurs mais
baissé le produit de tout ce qui est est
ce qui vous était arrivé avant oui
d'abord que je pense que je fais partie
de ces gens qui ont souillé leur corps
qui ont connu les limites de leur corps
qui les ont dépassés et à force de
dépasser ses limites qui mieux que
quelqu'un qui ait dépassé ces limites
qui a souillé son corps est à même de
dire aux autres ce qui est bon pour eux
si dès lors qu'ils travaillent contre
intuitif on pourrait se dire a priori
vous êtes mal placés pour venir me
baudelot d'aidé permanent moi je pense
que je suis le meilleur dès lors que
j'ai fait des formations naturopathie et
c est que je sais ce qui est très
mauvais pour mon corps et ma chique
abbott de dire attention si tu fais ça
ça va pas être bon après il ya aussi
l'envié de gagner envie de réussir de
construire j'ai toujours aimé ma que
m'occuper des autres j'ai toujours eu
cette volonté de partager j'ai beaucoup
d'amour à donner et je les injecter ce
les injecter dans
l'entrepreneuriat ça a marché pendant
des années et puis à un moment donné
j'ai fait une dépression nerveuse j'ai
sombré j'ai perdu manche et
ça s'est cassé la gueule ouais mais
comme souvent ça se casse la gueule chez
vous et en fait vous repartez et voilà
un peu toujours le cas chaque fois plus
joyeusement on a beau action mais je
crois que c'est une joyeuse la vie doit
être une joyeuse et je veux dire la la
souffrance fait partie de la vie la
difficulté fait partie de la vie et je
crois que c'est de la souffrance des
épreuves que naît une certaine
exaltation du combat une certaine joie
du combat moi je qu'entends je quand
j'ai tout perdu il ya quelques mois
qu'il a failli repartir à zéro je me
suis reparti mais la fleur au fusil
comme si j'avais 25 ans et j'ai monté ce
magazine suis en train de monter un
groupe fut de nouveau dans une levée de
fonds avec un super truc on va prendre
soin de soi pour prendre soin de la
planète on monte un groupe la partie
média c'est le magazine mentor ouais
c'est quelque chose qui est formidable
on est en train de changer le monde mais
encore une fois je suis habité par des
idées qui sont plus grandes que moi et
qui me donne envie de me lever le matin
l europe doit en arrière quand vous
lancez
dans la musique qu'il ya plusieurs
bonnes fées qui se penchent sur votre
berceau le producteur de robbie williams
ou yan yan philippe blanc qui était le
patron de la warner et vous vous signez
avec max guazini qui veut faire de vous
une sorte ça c'était votre disque avec
avec les hommes il veut faire de vous
une sorte de dalida tatoué barak est pas
du tout ce que vous avez un buteur
pourquoi vous le choisissez lui alors
que les autres étaient là ils
n'attendaient que vous moi alors c'est
un tout petit peu plus subtil que ça
passe quand on lit lips sait si j'avais
eu le choix j'aurais été évidemment avec
diane qui était non seulement un
extraordinaire dénicheur de talents et
un super businessman il se trouve que
c'est max qui m'a donné ma chance qui
m'a fait signer un contrat et j'ai été
en exploitation chez universal et je
n'ai pas été chez warner comme je
l'aurais voulu en l'occurrence
c'est olivier nusse qui est devenu mon
producteur qui est aujourd'hui le grand
pat le grand patron d'universal mais le
problème en appréciant aussi pardon vous
interrompre mais que vont vous êtes
pressé j'ai souvent très sage je suis un
voilà vous êtes pressé de signer je suis
très impatiente là c'est que par moments
il faut pas signé d'abord il faut
prendre son temps et puis je pense qu'à
l'époque j'étais vraiment le j'étais une
sorte de petit look de petits paysans
qui venait de sa bretagne
je me sentais risque de plein d'avenir
possible j'avais soif d'absolu je
faisais confiance à tout le monde moi
olivier nusse il m'avait fait plein de
promesses à l'époque en disant
t'inquiète pas c'est pas max qui va
commander puis en l'occurrence max camps
quand guy chambers me dit moi je vais
faire tout l'album ça c'est le
producteur de robbie williams est celle
d'un café de tous les tubes de robbie
williams james blunt dit dauphin l'an
passé des meilleurs il avait vendu 50
millions d'albums à l'époque donc
c'était lunaire pour moi que ce n'est
que la veille d'aller travailler pour
moi et maxime tu es mon bébé je le
connais pas c'est lui qui décide si
c'est le public qui décide on va leur
donner on va leur demander leur fait
écouter quand même donné je veux que tu
chantes le français qui va chanter
petula clark voilà moi j'avais envie de
mettre une balle déjà à l'époque je
disais c'est pas possible et le problème
c'est que comme c'était le patron de la
musique et ben
le patron de mon label s'est incliné et
donc vous allez vous-en relevé un peu de
cet échec patent ce parce que le disque
a pas marché du tout puisque c'est là
que vous allez devenir un activiste au
fond à la fois avec fitnext vous allez
faire de la télévision vous allez vous
mettre à écrire des livres qui vont
avoir de grands succès
pour nous plus empoisonné nos enfants ou
ou face à la la prochaine extinction on
va en voir un certain nombre tout ça au
fond ça se marie bien je veux dire est
ce qu'on peut être un activiste un
lanceur d alerte faire de la télé
alors d'abord
quand on dit la vérité c'est jeanne est
simple on se fait toujours taper sur les
doigts alors il faut avoir une certaine
forme de naïveté pour croire qu'on est
capable de changer les choses quel que
soit le niveau auquel on se place
quand j'ai décidé de parler pour le
cyclisme tout le monde m'a dit mais
ferme ta gueule ça va être tombé dessus
j'ai ouvert ma gueule ça a été un
best-seller qui avait traduit en
plusieurs langues ça n'a rien changé
mais on m'a bien la paix la guerre à
l'époque quand j'étais en télé je me
suis disputé avec de nombreux nombreux
nutritionnistes des médecins à qui
disait énormément de conneries mes
livres se sont vendus comme des petits
pains et j'ai participé à lancer des
alertes qui derrière en vue des projets
de loi qu on est encore aujourd'hui
l'analyse s'est pas forcément le bon
endroit à ben non on pallie le dire à la
télé non peut pas être payé par la télé
pour le dire j'ai payé pour le savoir
hier je suis resté pendant deux ans avec
stéphane bern puis à un moment donné on
a dit écoutez roi bien trop de papier
bleu maintenant il va falloir que soit
tu fasses le gentil en salopette et puis
que tu fasses qu'on te dit soit tu vas
partir donc je suis parti je suis revenu
après avec daphné bürki et j'ai vu que
c'était plus du tout la peine oui c'est
ça
ne ne pas se donner en exemple c'est ça
un peu le principe chez vous mais que ce
soit qu'on faisait une appli de coaching
ou dans ce livre ou dans votre magazine
mentor dont on reparlera vous donné par
exemple 20 ans vous incarner
physiquement et mentalement le projet
l'entreprise
est au fond c'est un peu antinomique
c'est à dire que là vous vous donnez pas
en exemple dans ce livre vous montrer à
quel point vous avez pu voir et un
certain nombre de trucs et en même temps
j'ai envie de dire c'est dégueu moi de
chanter pour la couverture voyez pas ça
veut pas ça peut pas être autre chose
que moi ces années je sais bien mais
c'est une mise à nu c'est une façon
il ya une intensité dramatique dans le
regard pour dire voilà j'ai sacrément
manger oui mais je suis encore cette
histoire de prison oui bon c'est pas de
prison mais d'un hôpital psychiatrique
peut-être non mais je veux dire par là
que à la fois voulez pas vous donner un
exemple et en même temps vous êtes le
meilleur exemple que vous avez sous la
main
en tout cas ce n'était pas mon but parce
qu'il ya quelque chose qui m'a
profondément mis mal à l'aise au cours
des dix dernières années parce qu'on
voyait sur des couvertures de magazines
mes livres se vendaient comme des petits
pains et les gens s'attendaient à ce que
je sois le reflet exact de tout ce qu'il
disait sauf que je suis plein de choses
à côté et j'ai de mes démons j'ai mes
contradictions à côté nous pour moi
chaque jour qui passe c'est un combat
chaque jour qui passe est une victoire
j'ai perdu 35 personnes depuis 2000 qui
se sont suicidés ou qui sont morts des
cancers de ma génération qui ont fait
souvent le même métier que vous des gens
ont fait la même chose que moi qui ont
été coureur cycliste professionnel ou
des boxeurs
il ya quelque chose qui m'appelle c'est
pour ça que j'ai glissé un jour où je
suis toujours sur le fil et je voudrais
pas que les gens s'imaginent que je suis
le plus équilibré des mecs jeunes en
gras pour être équilibré et je sais ce
qu'il faut faire pour être équilibré
mais ça veut pas dire que je le fais
tout le temps parce que c'est un combat
pour moi mais j'essaie de donner le
meilleur de moi vous avez l'entraînement
maintenant en fait on a l'impression que
rien ne peut rien ne peut vous détruire
vous ben c'est ce que j'ai cru pendant
un moment jusqu'à ce que j'explose ouais
mais je pense qu'aujourd'hui je en fait
je crois que pour pour tout un chacun à
un moment donné si on a un environnement
affectif solide on a beaucoup plus de
chances de survivre et de tenir sauf
qu'à un moment donné moi je me suis
retrouvé dans une situation où ma femme
m'a quitté et je me suis trouvée
extrêmement seul et perdu et j'avais
beau gagner plein d'argent d'avoir
beaucoup de réussite vandelli on être à
la télé tout ça ne servait à rien par
rapport aux bouffes que j'avais dans la
poitrine et qui me ramenait à mon
enfance et qui crée chez moi une
angoisse profonde une voix profonde de
vivre et une angoisse profonde de mourir
et je n'arrivais pas à régler et j'ai
été dépassé par sa pendant quelques
années sur le plan physique comme sur le
plan mental au fond vous êtes resté à un
sportif de haut niveau une occasion
c'est à dire à la fois
capable d'efforts surhumains vous êtes
capable de travailler
plus que n'importe qui de se surpasser
aussi ça aussi et puis aussi toujours de
résister à l'appel de la bim parce qu'il
ya un abîme au fond vous disiez tout à
l'heure résister à l'appel de la bim des
fois je suis c'est bien flirter avec la
bible quand même aimé justement on
dirait qu'il ya il ya toujours un abîme
pour d'après quand on vous lit on a
l'impression que chez les sportifs
d'autres compétitions il ya toujours un
abîme ce qui n'est pas forcément évident
pour les gens qui les admirent ou qui
dit regarde
non c'est sûr qui est une espèce de
vertige à la tentation
et à la tentation du pire on est on vit
tellement à la limite la limite physique
la limite 6 psychique intellectuelle et
ça c'est vrai ça seulement dans le
cyclisme et dans la boxe je viens
pression c'était vrai dans le sport
qu'est ce que c'est que le sport en gros
si on l'a pris en une manière
psychanalytique c'est je défie les lois
de la nature c'est à dire je défie dieu
je suis un dieu j'arrive à faire ce que
les autres font pas et quand on prend
conscience qu'on n'est pas un dieu et
ben là on redevient humain et on aspire
à la mort on a cette pulsion de mort
comme ça que vous le voyez que je le
ressens en tout cas ça encourage passer
ça t'es sûr c'est ça
ça encourage pas faire de nos enfants
des des tennismen alors si c'est pour le
dimanche mois j'encouragerai aucun
enfant à faire du sport de compétition
professionnelle
surtout pas donc aujourd'hui vous faites
quoi une fois que ce livre est sorti et
ah ouais quand et où là je suis en train
de monter un groupe je termine je boucle
la première grosse levée de fonds pour
faire une nouvelle application
d'ailleurs cynthia fleury nous aide à le
faire les filons d'ailleurs défini sur
la définition de l'om est de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé du
bien-être bien-être physique et mental
comme l'était fitnext mais avec le
maintenant le bien-être social
ça c'était déjà dans mentor le magazine
que vous avez là s'arrête dans une
application il y aura aussi une
marketplace moi ça fait 15 ans qu'on me
dit toujours est-ce que ça c est
coresponsable est-ce que ça c'est bio
est-ce que ça c'est et tigon va pouvoir
aller sur une plate forme et tout ce
qu'on choisira dessus on aura la
garantie que tout est éthique bio
système ball etc et de l'autre côté on
aura une appli de coaching alimentaire
sportif mentale et qui pourra gérer ce
sera une nouvelle interface qui pour moi
être aussi descriptif que la souris à un
moment donné c'est qu'on va avoir un
personal well being assistante un
assistant personnel de santé avec lequel
on va interagir avec la voix et avec un
certain nombre d'outils de salses
tracking qui nous dira toujours où on en
est et qui nous guidera pour nous
accompagner au quotidien pour être en
bonne santé et trier aussi ce qui va mal
pour vous donner un ordre d'idée il sera
même connecter à notre portable pour
savoir combien de temps passez sur quel
réseau pourquoi et au cas quel moment
grâce aux machines learning quand on
fait ça ça et ça et que tu passes tant
de temps là-dessus mais là tu es mal par
contre quand tu fais pas ça que tu fais
ça et ça l'a t bien donc tu va
interpréter pourquoi tu es bien et
pourquoi tu es mal et à partir de là
plus le 7 personnes passent de temps sur
l'api plus elle a de chances d'être en
bonne santé quand vous avez fait à
augmenter ou alors que vous aviez été
cycliste est dopé et pas une star en
même temps donc
puis puis d'avoir fait de la télévision
d'avoir fait d'avoir été préparateur
physique comment vous avez fait pour
vous faire accepter des scientifiques
des intellectuels que vous avez réussi à
séduire qui sont intervenus dans vos
livres mais je parle des livres les plus
graves que vous avez écrit sur l'avenir
de la planète ou houdan mentor le
magazine ou aujourd'hui j'imagine dans
le groupe qui est en train de déclarer
autour de mentor alors je sais pas si
c'est un an il faudrait poser la
question est plutôt à eux je pense que
d'abord j'ai lu énormément je me suis
beaucoup documenté je suis passionnée de
lecture je suis un insatiable curieux je
nourris des gens je suis passionné par
les gens et je pense que
si vous regardez aujourd'hui dans la
sphère politique ils savent tous ils
disent jamais qu'ils savent pas moi je
dis toujours je ne sais pas je peux être
avec quelqu'un s'y dit quelque chose que
je ne sais pas je dis je ne sais pas est
ce que tu peux m'expliquer et à force
les gens vont développer une certaine
forme de tendresse pour moi en disant oh
bah écoute il est un peu con mais on va
l'aider à être un peu plus intelligent
mais là vous exagérez parce qu'en fait
vous passez pour pour les gens pour
faire partie des gens qui savent
aujourd'hui alors on peut ne pas être
d'accord avec vous on peut considérer
que vous avez une vision un peu trop
tragique de l'humanité de l'effondrement
en tout cas du risque de l'effondrement
et mais vous passez pour ceux qui sont
informés dans ce domaine oui c'est
beaucoup de travail vous que c'est bien
de faire mon troisième livre donc
forcément quand on quand on travaille
c'est qu'on a quelque chose en soi et
puis je pense que je dois je dois
peut-être avoir un bon processeur et
j'essaye de mettre le maximum de plugins
dedans pour qu'il s'amplifie
l'histoire d'une vie c'est aussi de
s'amplifier puis d'être avec des gens
comme
vous avez réussi à passer du statut de
cyclistes à celui des intellectuels ce
n'est pas donné à tout le monde et vous
l'avez fait vite en plus ouais j'ai mis
les bottes de sept lieues médiation je
vous le dois en grande partie
parce qu'elle est bien certain temps
mais pas ou quoi vous étiez déjà bien
bien formés et en même temps en
racontant tout ça dans ce livre
maintenant vous êtes en train de lever
des fonds pour vous rendez bien compte
que sa silice sizes on la lui peut-être
que a est dangereux voilà peut-être
qu'il est dangereux alors on voit bien
que vous avez une mentalité enfin vous
avez un moral de fer d'acier dans 20 ans
on sait que demain
sait jamais alors on sait bien que
peut-être demain je peux péter les
plombs mais qui aujourd'hui dans cette
société
n'est pas au bord de la crise de nerfs
qui n'est pas en danger d'un point de
vue psychologique
il n'y en a pas
ce monde rend fou on est en train
aujourd'hui de parler d'un mec qui
risque qui ne s'est pas encore prêt se
présenter à la présidentielle qui tient
des discours xénophobes qu'on n'aurait
jamais accepté dans nos temps il a été
condamné trois fois on ne parle que de
lui en france mais ya de quoi devenir
barjots iroquois devenir un barjot dans
plein d'autres compartiments de cette
société au moins vous vous vous êtes en
train de vous dire moi je suis déjà
devenu barjots dont vous pouvez me faire
confiance selon les besoins moi j'ai
fleurs j'ai flirté plein de fois avec la
folie j'ai flirté avec les limites de
mon corps je sais ce qui est mauvais
pour moi et je sais ce qui est bon pour
moi et j'ai une certaine une certaine
idée de la vie qui va me faire tendre
vers une forme de justice mais en même
temps je suis très jeune très libéral
pour moi c'est pas l'état mon père moi
je suis libéral et j'ai beaucoup de mal
avec l'idée qu'on doive toujours
attendre des autres qu'on fasse les
choses moi je fais ce qui est bon pour
moi va vous me demandiez pourquoi je me
suis mis à réfléchir parce que j'ai
décidé de faire ce qui est bon pour moi
et j'ai la volonté d'aider les autres
mais ce monde dans lequel on vit il est
tragiquement dangereux et il est fou il
devient fou enfin aujourd'hui ce qui a
fait la beauté de l'homme son expansion
extraordinaire le développement de
toutes les techniques et ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui on arrive à une fin de
cycle qui va qui va tuer le vivant sur
la terre c'est quand même de la folie et
tout conspire à nous rendre fous sur
cette planète ça s'appelle résistant
c'est signé awad menthéour et ça sort
chez cela merci erwann menthéour ont
fait une pause on se retrouve juste
après avec richard martin qui fêtent le
50e anniversaire du théâtre toursky
[Musique]
et sur martin bonjour comédien metteur
en scène auteur êtes le fondateur du
théâtre toursky un théâtre mythique
international et populaires dans les
quartiers nord de marseille qui fête son
50e anniversaire et les images qui
symbolise pour vous notre époque c'est
celle ci pourquoi
oui parce que je crois avoir compris que
c'était foutu quand j'ai entendu ces
gars-là dire à la télévision qu'il
fallait avoir une rolex à 50 balais pour
avoir réussi sa vie donc là j'ai
commencé à prendre du recul et à
observer la descente donc on est
maintenant tout près du gouffre je suis
pas étonné mais catastrophé par la
situation alors le le toursky le théâtre
toursky c'est quoi alors pour tous ceux
qui ne le connaissent pas
petite bande annonce un extrait parce
qu'elle est tellement longue
extraits mais déjà on se fait une idée
le toursky
c'est parti
[Musique]
le toursky
c'est parti
[Musique]
c'était
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le toursky c'est parti le toursky ses
parties de tours ce que c'est parti le
toursky c'est parti mais saint barth à
vous êtes chauds voulu faire un théâtre
populaire dès le début en 71 quand vous
créez le théâtre toursky d'ailleurs dans
les quartiers nord de marseille
je crois même au début vous alliez en
bus carrément dans les quartiers pour
c'est quoi pour vous un théâtre
populaire parce que c'est tabou que tout
bon emploi aujourd'hui mais quel sens
est il pour vous ben c'est un théâtre où
tout le monde a envie d'entrer et en
savoir davantage dans ce monde où tout
le monde cherche à prendre quelque chose
dans la poche des autres plutôt que la
compétition c'est la recherche et
l'envié d'en savoir davantage ou
partager la fraternité je crois que tous
les théâtres de ce pays devrait être d d
d d d endroits de débats de rencontres
des changes de liberté d'un forum
permanent où les hommes essaient de
comprendre pourquoi ils sont là et à
quoi ça sert c'est parce que vous vous
l'avez vous lu votre théâtre populaire à
vous voulez vous voulu éclectique
ambitieux et pas cher
absolument j'ai surtout voulu faire un
pied-de-nez à la misère puisque je suis
venu sur les traces d'une aventure qui
s'appelle et le théâtre quotidien de
marseille après les événements de 68 à
paris je suis je suis parti
j'avais travaillé à l'odéon pour les
faux pour les forums et j'avais compris
qu après qu après ces événements là il
fallait réinventer chacun des choses
différentes j'avais draguer un peu tous
ceux du cartel et tout ce qu'ils avaient
penser le théâtre pour tous et je me
suis dit que personne ne me donnerait
ici la possibilité de cette aventure et
donc je suis allé en fabriquer une à
marseille parce que
j'avais été le jeune premier d'une
aventure qui s'appelait la famille
hernandez c'était
en fait à la télé ça a été ensuite mais
c'était un spectacle de théâtre qui
avait été créée
au g ans et qui ensuite a fait une
tournée européenne européenne et nous
avons fait les derniers les les quinze
derniers jours d'un théâtre mythique qui
s'appelait le l'alcazar arrêt
cette époque il fallait
vous avez députés constant voilà tout à
fait et donc nous l'avons fermé avec
avec ce spectacle on a fait les quinze
derniers jours mais je suis sorti
j'habitais sur le cours belsunce à côté
du à côté du théâtre un hôtel qui
s'appelait l'hôtel de provence et je
sortais sur ce court et tout d'un coup
j'avais l'impression d'être directement
connecté avec l'universel donc c'était
cosmopolite s'est il y avait des gens de
partout mais mais des gens qui
trimballait de la tendresse parce que
maintenant ça prend ça très mal de la
haine mais à l'époque on avait envie
tous de s'embrasser donc la fraternité
gelé pressenti
dans cet espace là réduit de du cours du
cours belsunce et quand après 68
j'ai compris qu'à macaques à paris les
choses se dé se dégrader je suis allé à
marseille retrouver cette ambiance en
suivant les pas d'une aventure qui
s'appelait le théâtre quotidien de
marseille le tqm qui avait vu les
premiers pas de vitesse et je suis allé
dans le quartier le plus déshérité
d'europe il sait qu ils disaient qu'ils
continuent à dire d'ailleurs pour faire
un pied-de-nez à cette misère et amener
les artistes les plus importants du
monde que ce soit dans tout dans toutes
les disciplines artistiques que parce
que cette enquête internationale
international louis de barbara hendricks
qui est venu ce qui est venu dans ceux
de ce théâtre
comme roberto de roberto de simone ou
des dix mètres des mets les plus grands
metteurs en scène russe sont sont venus
travailler là on a fabriqué des
aventures avec tout le temps mais c'est
50 balles et cinquante balais d'
aventure magique formidable fin de
course qui pour comme ski parce que
quand je suis arrivé à marseille en fait
j'ai été très surpris par
cette gloire pagnolesque qui ait fait
déborder qui allait dans tous les sens
alors que pagnol est un génie mais ça a
été récupéré d'une drôle de façon dans
cette ville est en fête
marseille devenait la paresse le pastis
les jeux de boules la partie de cartes
c'était voilà et non quand je suis
rentré dans ce dans ce théâtre qui
étaient en gare à nos hangars
désaffectés que gaston defferre avait
proposé de dogo d'occuper mais qui avait
été tout arraché après le départ de
cette troupe que j'ai recherché qui
avait était désolé de ne pas être
soutenus et reconnus par parler
politique non plus et
j'ai décidé
de mettre le nom d'un poète que l'on ne
connaissait pas et qui venait de mourir
le jour où j'ai mis le pied dans le
théâtre toursky qui a fait partie de la
bande des surréalistes qui a refusé de
partir avec la rose rouge
faire une carrière pas une carrière
parisienne je trouvais que ça me
plaisait bien j'ai pris une échelle qui
faisait peut-être 80 kg pour arriver au
loup à la façade
là oui là on voit pas de c'est parce que
ça a été refait et on voit qu'il ya des
qu'il ya des bandeaux sur la façade mais
pourquoi il ya des bandeaux il ya des
bandeaux parce que si vous enlevez la
fin si vous enlevez les si vous enlevez
les bandeaux l'aller les calicots vous
avez tout une tous les carreaux qui
tombe
donc je me bats depuis je redirai que
bon je vais pas m'étendre là dessus ce
qui m'intéresse avec vous c'est de vous
retrouver avec la tendresse et vous
parlez et les choses formidables que
nous avons encore depuis 50 ans en 50
ans quelles sont les plus grandes
victoires que vous avez remporté par
rapport aux objectifs que vous étiez
fixés
c'est d'être venu symboliquement un
espace d'un espace de résistance et les
victoires elles sont régulières parce
que chaque fois qu'il ya un artiste qui
vient dans cette maison c'est une fête
chaque fois qu'il ya un créateur qui
vient offrir
un moment de poésie partager c'est un
cadeau superbe dans ce monde où on ne
pense qu'à mettre la main dans la poche
des autres tout d'un coup continuer à
expliquer qu'on est dans la fiction et
qu' il n'y a qu'une voie possible
maintenant qu'il donne la direction de
l'essentiel ce sont les poètes quoi
suivront les poètes et vos plus gros
échec ce serait quoi alors
et ben peut-être ces deux pas réussi à
convaincre les gens qu'ils auraient dû
porter cette aventure et qui est
non non non rien fait pour là pour la
soutenir alors que ça aurait pu être que
ça aurait pu déborder et devenir des
politiques ben oui c'est d'échouer sont
essentiellement des politiques je sais
pas si les politiques sont très
conscients de ce qui se passe autour
d'eux ce qu'ils délèguent et que l
arrivée les politiques passent mais
c'est toujours les mêmes techniciens qui
reste d'administration de
l'administration je crois que j'ai pas
envie de faire de procès
personne je suis joyeux scénario n'est
quand même pas ce que l époque on a
beaucoup plus à parler de bourdes 2009
quand tout à coup vous retrouver
totalement privées de subventions il
vous fait une grève de la faim qui
avaient duré quand même douze jours vous
avez 85 mille personnes qui ont signé
une pétition pour vous soutenir vous
aviez un comité de soutien extrêmement
prestigieux avec aussi bien michel
bouquet que pierre arditi
qu'est ce que je fais ça a été le
premier avait pas pour ça cette affaire
non mais la première grève parce que il
faut savoir se réfugier obligé d'en
faire plus tant que c'est la seule arme
que c'est la seule arme que j'avais je
me suis je m'en suis servi à réparer
pétition mal malheureusement mais enfin
quand même quoi qu'il advienne nous
sommes toujours là ouais et beaucoup
beaucoup sont passés qui n'avait pas
compris ce que je fabriquais mais
beaucoup maintenant continue à
fréquenter ce lieu qui malheureusement
n'est pas vraiment comme les autres
j'espèrerais que tous les théâtres soit
ce soit comme ça quelque chose serait
sauvée qu'est ce qu'il ya en ce moment
au théâtre toursky alors il ya eu
égalité de n'avoir et endure justement a
pas encore d'accord mais il va tenir
celle là vous conseille de de vous
rendre compte de ce qu'est cet artiste
syriens réfugiés
dont personne ne voulait et dont j'ai
présenté son spectacle pressé précédent
et je me suis levé à la fin du spectacle
en pleure tellement ce set cet artiste
est formidable yann boutboul rappelez
vous de ça c'est un artiste superbe
exceptionnel vue des jeux le dip je ne
dis pas souvent je suis je suis pas
forcément porté sur
sur les superlatifs et non au toursky à
une salle de théâtre très grande et puis
il ya eu deux concerts dont il ya aussi
pierre perret je crois vendredi prochain
lui aussi avec pierre parce que vouloir
que pierre aussi chaque fois qu'il
venait au tour ce qui travaillait avec
les les enfants de la maternelle d'à
côté qui pendant des mois avait répété
le répertoire de pierre et ensemble
quand il arrivait toute la journée il
chantait ensemble c'était ce sont des
choses comme ça qui se tissent qui sont
précieuses et que les gens ne savent pas
il ya aussi soin de mon fils ça c'est en
ce moment soit un homme monte ici en ce
moment à paris ouais voilà oui donc ça a
été créée à marseille c'est bouchta
aussi un comédien à découvrir c'est un
comédien
d'origine algérienne qui c'est la divine
comédie ce qui est à la divine comédie
et qui a fait un travail formidable sur
sur son sur son vécu c'est à dire qu'il
a cette politesse extraordinaire cette
délicatesse du coeur de nous faire rire
sur une tragédie si vous découvrez
l'histoire de bouchta qui a été mariée
de force par sa mère pour pas qu'on dise
que il était qu'il était homosexuel
il s'est dit on l'a mis dans tous les
pièges mais il s'est sorti de tous ces
pièges avec un sourire de l'âme
formidable voilà encore quelqu'un
quelqu'un à découvrir mais là c'est un
échec pour moi parce que ce garçon qui
est né dans un bidonville à marseille et
qui était voisin du qui étaient voisins
du tour ce qui a mis 40 ans pour mettre
les pieds dans ce théâtre enfin il les
amis et
maintenant il est aux dernières la
divine comédie à paris desriac testions
richard martin qu'est ce qui a changé
dans le théâtre pour vous en cinquante
ans le théâtre des années 2000 c'est pas
le même que celui des était saoul de 70
le terrain ne change pas
le théâtre c'est
cesser cet ascenseur etc sans
extraordinaire qui nous permet de voler
un un peu plus haut que noël longue
voilà et
quelles que soient les fautes il ya
toujours mille formes de théâtre mais il
yal'art larves et serment de
résurrection je disait léo qui est mon
complice fondamental
au me
on ne s'en sortira qu'avec ça je dis
cela au moment où tout le monde s'est
planté où on en voit des gamins faire
des compétitions de ce monde de
compétition
alors où on leur fait croire justement
qui sont dans cette fiction sociale
le théâtre par expérience puisque
on expérimente le malheureusement
expérimenté ça devrait être partout dans
toutes les aidants toutes les écoles bon
faudrait revenir sur tous les systèmes
non mais voilà mais en tout cas nous
notre expérience avec
un point un professeur d'école et des
quartiers nord une fille formidable qui
écrit les pièces pour c'est pour ces
élèves etc et qui nous amène des gamins
brut au départ on se demande s'ils vont
pas nous couper le cou et que deux ans
après ce sont des êtres splendide ce
sont des gens fantastiques
qu'on a immédiatement envie d'embrasser
et qu'on appelle pour cette fraternité
comme
de noby d'art qui nous rejoint pour les
fêtes de la fraternité qui a écrit les
offres ce plaidoyer plus ce plaidoyer
pour la fraternité et la lettre et la
lettre aux musulmans que je conseille à
tout le monde de le lire parce que là au
moment où on s'enfonce c'est c'est un
soleil c'est que dire oui c'est possible
c'est possible mais pas possible comme
ça pas comme ils veulent non non non
c'est pas comme ça c'est pas comme ça ça
rien ne se fera sans le sang le coeur
c'est pas possible parce que le cerveau
il avance paraît mais il avance avec le
coeur ou c'est peut-être le coeur qui
avance avec le cerveau mais peut-être
que c'est d'abord le cercueil faut
peut-être d'abord s'occuper du du
cerveau jeu
j'imagine magie non mais ça veut dire
qu'il faut tout refaire
ça me rappelle une histoire si j'ai le
temps de la ville de les raconter très
très vite quand je suis arrivé à paris
pour faire ce métier de saltimbanque
comme je n'avais pas d'argent j'ai un
ami qui faisait
sup de co donc allez manger là bas à sup
de co au resto u
avec un bal
je
mangeais mais j'en profitais pour
quelquefois me glisser dans
l'amphithéâtre et voir les
ce que mes copains recevez comme
éducation et j' ai écouté un jour j'ai
écouté un jour un des précurseurs de ces
gars là qui est maurice schumann pas
celui de l'europe
un ministre de gaulle qui a fini sa
conférence je vous la fait courte en
disant de toute façon quoique vous
fassiez
demandez vous si ça vaut le coup c'est
aux ut
pas un gamin a réagi quoi il ya que moi
et me dit mais il est fou et je me suis
employé toute ma vie c'est de rendre
les choses différentes et que si ça vaut
le coup c ou ipcc tonnes c'est un acte
mais c'était déjà c'est bon ça annonce
et séguéla qui a annoncé tapis gdansk et
voilà où voilà où on en est alors
revoyons le revoyons la copie
aimons-nous enfin le théâtre toursky
donc fête son 50e anniversaire merci
richard martin devenue un peu le fêter
ici ah oui j'aurais voulu rendre hommage
à tous ces artistes formidables du monde
entier et peut-être un jour je vous en
parlerai
[Musique]
le pierre promeneurs vous n'êtes pas un
trait vous êtes exposés à la galerie
frédéric roulettes avenue de messine à
paris guy qui vous soutient depuis 20
ans et en février vous serez à la maison
rouge à saint sauveur en puisaye dans
l'yonne votre image à vous on va la voir
tout de suite
c'est un vieux téléphone oui c'est un
vieux téléphone portable et il est vieux
et fort heureusement il est vieux et
j'ai dit à votre assistante tout à
l'heure que c'était une cochonnerie et
que donc c'est votre donc c'est votre tv
ciment téléphone mais mon téléphone est
devenu une cochonnerie mais il est par
essence la cochonnerie de cette époque
il me semble en effet que cette époque
est devenue complètement folle à partir
de cet appareil en mettant en
magnificence ce que j'appelle le troll
eu trop de tout le trot des images en
définitive aussi et je vous prie de m'en
excuser mais ici les mots honteux je le
pense et je le sais une profondeur mais
il y a trop d'artifices
sans feu et il me semble que le devoir
des artistes dont il semblerait que je
fasse partie est de mettre désormais le
feu aux artifices
et pourquoi vouloir séparer pas de ce
téléphone mais je devine cochon mais je
vous dirai en même temps je ne sais même
pratiquement pas m'en servir même de
celui là oui bon danseur est
rudimentaire même de celui ci est fort
heureusement il a un écran tout à fait
rudimentaire donc sur lequel je
n'aperçois aucune image ce qui me
conforte dans mon point de vue que la
maladie de cette époque est une maladie
des images et non seulement une maladie
des images mais une certaine maladie par
l'intermédiaire de l'image qui ramène à
un mot splendide de sénèque qui disait
il faut séparer les choses du bruit
qu'elles font et donc il faut séparer le
temps des images dans lequel nous sommes
et dans lequel nous sommes est
excessivement est trop plongé puisque il
me semble que les vies et nous sommes
arrivés à une époque du trot et 7 et ce
n'est pas un trop de cheval pur sang oui
c'est un un trop de mauvais cheval
abîmée je ne dis pas du mal du cheval je
dis du mal des cavaliers des cavaliers
d'aujourd'hui on oublié peut-être si
vous me permettez ce terme le sens de la
chevalerie vous faites des peintures pas
des croquis on va voir demain qu'on
pourrait croire que ce sont des croquis
oui parce que c'est toujours en noir et
blanc mais ce sont des peintures
généralement réalisées sur du carton
elles ne sont jamais date et ce sont des
peintures morale dit vous qu'est ce que
vous entendez par là alors je vais vous
répondre et puis je trouve je vous
remercie d'avoir souligné le fait
qu'elle ne soit jamais date et il y à un
mot magnifique de man ray qui dit ceci
et que je prends pour moi aussi s'il
veut bien me le permettre du haut de ses
nuages
je n'ai jamais peint de tableaux récents
et donc j'espère que en ce qui me
concerne mes tableaux soient plus
récents soit plus intéressant que récent
et on va voir les tableaux parce que là
on voit surtout des choses écrit mais il
est à bout et derrière on arrive à ce
propos pourquoi les peintures moral
pourquoi les peintures murales les
peintures moral et dans cette exposition
vous avez passé à un moment donné le
carton qui dit simplement qu'est ce que
c'est que ce que fait ce peintre ce
peintre est en état de description c'est
à dire qu'il décrit est en décrivant il
écrit et cela veut dire quoi cela veut
dire qu'il se sert
des formes et de ses formes il en fait
des idéogrammes c'est à dire que tant
que lorsque l'on est devant un tableau
en lit une série d'idéogrammes vous avez
un chien vous avez un homme vous avez un
visage de femme vous avez d'une certaine
façon aussi la feuille n'est ce pas la
feuille qui est toujours là parce que
les feuilles tombent et si vous me
permettez ce terme elle ne tombe pas
dans l'oreille d'un sourd
mais c'est le réel que vous décrivez
absolument c'est la solim ans pourquoi
parce que j'ai le sentiment que le réel
est plus imaginatifs que l'imaginaire et
que nous on dit l'imaginaire la folle du
logis c'est exactement le moment dans
qu'elle ne nous nous nous sommes les
gens se sont laissé prendre par la folle
du logis alors vous me parliez la
peinture morale pourquoi la peinture
murale la peinture murale à ce cet
élément extrêmement simple mais
semble-t-il à comprendre en tous les cas
moi pour l'instant je le comprends et
qui est ce si il est plus beau de se
ternir droit que se tenir avachi et de
moisir dans son avachissement pourquoi
parce que l'objectif de d'une vie me
semble-t-il est le titre de cette
exposition vous le savez le premier
titre et les merveilleuses pourquoi les
merveilleuses parce que le devoir d'un
artiste et d'émerveiller et de donner
aux gens la capacité de s'apercevoir que
dans le magma du réel simplement la
manière de le regarder peut le rendre
beau et vous savez il ya ceux à ce sujet
un mot splendide de gustave flaubert qui
disait peau qu'une chose soit belle il
suffit de la regarder l'entente est ce
que fait l'artiste ce que fait l'artiste
il donne aux gens la capacité de se
rendre compte que dans un seul instant
l'artiste c'est à dire celui qui leur
dit il ya quelque chose là et il leur
donne un temps infime ni carla me
semble-t-il est l'élément d'un temps
infini donc nous avons dix peintures
morale le l'objet de cette exposition
est de dire la beauté est belle mais le
courage est plus beau que la beauté
pourquoi parce que nous nous apercevons
que il me semble mais je peux me tromper
que toutes les vies
entre pour objectif d'être beau d'être
le cas échéant trouver beau et non
seulement ça pouvait vous et je
quelqu'un pour utile me dire s'il
connaît une personne dans l'objectif est
de devenir les ça n'existe pas autrement
dit ce que ceux qui nous frappent dans
la beauté et la définition que je
pourrais avoir de la beauté on fait ce
qu'on peut mais moi j'en ai une alors on
peut la discuter et bien sûr on peut la
discuter mais cette définition est la
suivante la beauté c'est l'héroïsme des
formes l'héroïsme des formes et pourquoi
parce que vous avez vu que dans ce
tableau qui si je puis dire est un
tableau manifeste dans lequel envoie ce
groupe de deux soldats qui vend
mitraillé un bonhomme c'était le tableau
qu'on voyait juste avant exactement et
le bonhomme lève le poing ce n'est pas
un point politique mais il sait que le
point c'est dire cette vie ne m'aura pas
je la vaincre et et je la vaincre et par
la beauté et lorsque l'on voit ça on se
dit mais d'une certaine façon en quoi on
peut me poser la question en quoi est-ce
que la beauté et l'héroïsme d'efforts
alors je réponds je répands ceci lorsque
nous disons tout simplement c'est beau
ce si c'est beau cela c'est beau cette
jeune femme c'est beau ce nuage qui
passe nous sommes de vente une sensation
qui est de cet ordre très curieux très
étrange en soi est très simple qui est
que nous voyons à ce moment là
un élément dans lequel il nous avons la
sensation le sentiment l'intuition de
nous trouver de vente une une structure
visuel et émotionnel qui nous donne
l'impression de voir une sorte de
quelqu'un droit souriant devant un
précipice et n'ayant pas peur
est-ce que c'est toujours en noir et
blanc là aussi c'est parce qu'il ya trop
et rose la couleur et groove la couleur
exactement et pour une raison très
simple c'est que il me semble là aussi
je peux me tromper que nous sommes dans
la vie dans deux états et nous pouvons
les avoir momentanément le premier état
est un état musicale cela veut dire vous
savez il ya un mot qui est absolument
superbe et qui est un mot de lénine qui
disait je n'aime pas la musique parce
qu'elle me rends bon et cela veut dire
quoi cela veut dire que la musique nous
entraîne dans une
frénésie où notre volonté n'existe plus
et c'est merveilleux c'est charmant mais
l'autre point c'est la lecture c'est à
dire la littérature c'est à dire le
moment où l'on lit par l'intermédiaire
de la raison mais de la raison du coeur
ce que la page de la vie nous donne et
vous savez il y à un mot là aussi
splendide de d'alembert qui disait ceci
la raison finira par avoir raison eh
bien je donne raison à monsieur d'un
combat en art dit vous aussi le peu est
plus important que le bouc bien sûr et
c'est ce que je disais ce qu'il y à 2
parce que là on pourrait dire il ya
beaucoup de choses oui sur 7 sur 7 sur
cette oeuvre c'est exact vous avez vous
avez parfaitement raison de le dire mais
il y a entre les lignes il y à tout ce
qui se passe entre les lignes et
simplement ce sont des mots ce sont des
mots il y à ce monsieur qui n'a rien
demandé pour être sur
la table de la vie il est là il nancy ne
sais même pas pourquoi mais simplement
le peintre qui peint ceux ci lui dit
monsieur vous existez je vous ai vu vous
êtes grands pour une raison qui est la
première du courage vous continuez à
vivre vous continuez à vivre c'est ça le
grand courage et par exemple aujourd'hui
je suis venu vous voir je vous remercie
de votre invitation eh bien je me disais
en voyant tous ces gens qui vendent d'un
côté de l'autre et ma peinture ce sont
des gens qui vont d'un côté de l'autre
la différence c'est que je me permets de
dire vous êtes grands vous êtes beau et
vous savez il y à ce poème de baudelaire
qui dit ceci un matin nous partons le
cerveau plein de flammes le coeur gros
de rancune et de regrets amers et nous
allons suivant le rythme de la lame
berçant notre infinie sur le fini des
mères mais c'est somptueux rien que pour
ça on pourrait mourir et d'ailleurs à ce
sujet il y a ce mot splendide de
saint-exupéry qui dit ceci un sourire et
souvent l'essentiel on est charmé par un
sourire on it animé par un sourire et la
qualité d'un sourire peut faire que l'on
meurt et si vous me permettez encore un
mot à propos de quelqu'un qui viennent
mourir c'est à dire ce monsieur je crois
qu'il s'appelle germain qui a été un des
compagnons de la libération et je ne
parle pas du benchama gilbert germain je
fais pas de
gaullisme pagonis ça ne m'intéresse pas
ce qui m'intéresse c'est que cet homme a
été beau parce qu'elle était courageux
et parmi ce qui est de l'ordre de la
beauté vous avez prenez un bellâtre qui
fait se pâmer et les femmes et les
jeunes femmes et moi j'aime bien les
jeunes femmes
mais est un torero intérêts rôle et le
torero et dans l'arène il est face au
taureau qui est le plus beau c'est
l'homme les
merveilles heures c'est donc à la
galerie frédéric roulettes et puis
ensuite
ce sera dans l'yonne à la maison rouge
merci c'est moi merci aux mineurs d'être
passé par cette émission merci de nous
avoir suivis et rendez vous au prochain
numéro
[Musique]